let me say something about this picture
number one my wife both loves this
picture and hates this picture
because she was having a bad hair
year
[Music]
but
see when we decided to add to this add
to our family through adoption
she went to romania having no idea what
was going to happen who she was gonna
bring back if anybody she was gonna
bring back all we did was we wanted to
give some kid a chance that he didn't
have or she didn't have
and so this
this guy is almost three years old and
had been outside one day in his life and
that was the day he was found abandoned
in a park at birth
he'd been warehoused
in this in this romanian orphanage
[Music]
and the woman at the orphanage who
handed michael to cheryl
first child that cheryl laid eyes on
you know what she said to
cheryl don't take this boy he's no good
[Music]
don't take this boy he's no good
[Music]
and you wonder
as we bring cheryl brings michael home
and we
take him to the doctor and he goes to a
bunch of specialists because
the child she's holding right there
couldn't walk couldn't talk just made
noises
[Music]
had a foot that was totally turned in
and
i remember what my wife said on the
phone
it was that i
this guy's so much more than we can
handle
but i can't imagine going through the
rest of my life wondering what happened
to that blond-haired boy in that
orphanage
[Music]
and when they bring
him home and he gets diagnosed with
muscular dystrophy
and now he's three years old and he's
got this fatal disease and you don't
know
what you're going to do and how you're
going to handle that
you
wonder where's the value
[Music]
these was this
it's a woman who said don't take this
boy is no good
and what's amazing
is the value reveals itself
[Music]
and so
when michael
got through got to high school he's in a
wheelchair
[Music]
and a basketball coach
named phil beaulier is in
at mill creek high school
and and phil beaulieu hears michael's
wheelchair
going to a room and then he follows him
in there and and he get and he just
meets michael and he was like and then
the teacher's like well yeah this is
michael johnson he's got muscular
dystrophy and he's
a little bit
autistic he's got this incredible memory
never forgets cars and that kind of
thing that what you drive and and so
phil tells michael what kind of car he
drives and michael digs that and and and
then phil turns to leave and michael
says love you too coach
coach stranger i said what
and the teacher says he says that to
everybody love you too and he does
even if you don't say it to him first
that's always been that way
and he says well
phil bolear i didn't know him at all he
didn't know me he calls me he says i
want your son on my basketball team
because i wanted to teach my players
[Music]
maximum effort because i know every
ounce of strength he's got he uses to
drive this chair and i want to teach
a heart for others because this love you
too thing just floors me
[Music]
and
he said sure
you want him on your team but realize
he's in a wheelchair
and he's not going to be able to do much
for you offensively he said no he's
going to be my he's going to be my five
he's going to be my five foot tall
impact player with no vertical leap
because i just want my players hanging
around this guy
[Music]
and so while
while phil boulier is teaching and
coaching
[Music]
he's teaching his classes he'll just
bring up in the middle of it i want to
tell you all a story today just about a
buddy of mine named michael johnson and
he he loves to say love you too and he
says and you know what you know what
this sign is
this is this is i love you in sign
language
if you tip your index finger the other
person means love you too
so phil is teaching this to
thousands of kids at mill creek high
school
while michael is
part of that team and sitting behind the
bench during games
[Music]
and they had senior night at mill creek
high school michael did this for three
or four years
and on senior night all the players came
out
they got a blanket with mill creek
logo on it their name on it
seniors everybody glad the last the last
guy that they called out was michael
[Music]
and he gets out there
and they give him his blanket and stuff
and the crowd cheers and i look up in
the student section and they stand it
like this
[Music]
don't take but was no good
he had done more
through that point in his life and
impacted more folks than i could ever
hope to
because there is value inside everybody
[Music]
may not be able to do things the way we
all do it
[Music]
they have a different strength and
different weakness and that kind of
thing but there's always value find it
find it in those you work with
don't stress out over the things that
bug you
find that value and latch on to it
see that number 23 right there
two down from michael big kid
got married a couple months ago
so i gotta have michael at my wedding
don't take
boys no good
don't believe everything you hear
there's value in everybody
and there's value in this room
that you can't even put a number on
so proud to be in this number
with you all
no matter how tough the times can get
we'll always be turner
thanks
[Music]